if we want Duality to
end we need to look at the nature of the
subject what do we believe or
assume
is going on between our
ears why do we believe that there is
someone
Inside the
Mind that
is doing the
seeing or
hearing why do believe why do we believe
that there is someone in
there that is separate from the raw
experience because there's
not it's just so
obvious once you
really look at
it and just give it your time and
attention to notice that there was just
some sort of assumed
belief that there was a subject there
there was never a separate subject there
ever and this is why it's the end of
Duality what is appearing and the source
are one there's not a separate subject
that is looking at or
experiencing
appearances
the source and the appearance are the
same
thing and when there's no separate
subject that means there's no other
separate
subjects this alone is a
massive healing this alone is a massive
expansion out of the contracted feeling
of
Separation which is so painful
it's so painful to believe that there is
a self inside this head and there are
selves inside of other heads and now
we're going to war and fight against
each other based on our ideologies our
identities our boxes and our
labels that's where all suffering is is
right
there and once you know
clearly that there's no
subject you know that there's no
other there's only source with
appearance as one everywhere and that's
you you are not a separate self you are
everywhere and everything all at
once and therefore
nowhere and this is the ultimate healing
this is the ultimate realization the
ultimate love and you can
creatively Express from that place in a
holistic beautiful aesthetic truthful
good way that you so deeply
desire but it can't come from trying to
study Concepts
it can't come from accumulation of
knowledge Truth Good Beauty aesthetic
reality can only come from the
dissolution of the
subject there is no one
inside this alone is such
healing
the beauty of appearances without a
separate
subject the love that remains when all
Duality
ends The Duality between a separate
subject and objects of that
subject The Duality between a self and
others The Duality between the absolute
and the
relative between source and appearance
all those dualities go
away but it's all right there on that
Crux of there being a separate
subject
because there's
not if you look really
good between your
ears you will
find
nothing and that's
Freedom
that's
freedom